dimanche dimanche les français devront
choisir leur destin jamais jamais jamais
depuis la fondation de la vème
république un second tour n'aura été
aussi décisif pour notre avenir
jamais jamais a second tour n'aura été
aussi importants pour la vie de tous les
jours de chaque française de chaque
français la question
la question est simple allons nous
vraiment continuer cinq ans de plus avec
ceux qui depuis avec ce
avec ce
avec ceux qui depuis 20 ans ont enchaîné
notre pays ont abîmé notre société et
ont tant fait souffrir les français
[Applaudissements]
oui la question est simple allons nous
enfin reprendre notre destin en main car
ne vous trompez pas ne vous trompez pas
élire emmanuel macron ce françois
hollande junior immature
hollande junior immature et agité
reviendrait à en fermer définitivement
la france dans la prison de l'union
européenne
une union européenne qui n'a rien à voir
qui n'a rien à voir avec la belle europe
que nous voulons construire celle des
nations libres et des projets concrets
[Applaudissements]